- [Presenter] So let's
say I had the equation,
two x plus y is equal to eight.
This is an equation, one single
equation with two unknowns
and there's many different x, y pairs
that would satisfy this equation.
Now let's add a second equation,
x plus y is equal to five.
And once again, if we only
looked at the second equation,
there's many different x, y
pairs that would satisfy it,
you could have x is equal
to four, y is equal to one,
x is equal to three, y is equal to two.
Many, many, actually
there's an infinite number
that would satisfy this right over here.
But what's interesting
about a system of equations
is you're using both of these
equations as constraints.
You're saying, is there
at least one x, y pair
that would satisfy both
of these equations.
And as we'll see in many future videos,
this is a very useful thing
to think about in many,
not only fields of mathematics
but in many fields of knowledge generally.
But the focus of this video
is to think about why the
operations we can perform
on either or both of these equations,
why they are valid and
why they're intuitive.
So the first series of operations is when
we just try to manipulate
one equation by themselves.
So for example, we could
multiply both sides
of this purple equation, this
top equation by negative one,
you would get negative two x minus y
is equal to, you multiply the right side
by negative one as well, negative eight.
Now all I did right over here,
this is, you could do this
even if we weren't thinking about a system
is two x plus y is truly equal to eight,
we're assuming that that is true
because they're telling us that's true.
So if two x plus y is equivalent to eight,
then the negative of two x plus y
should be equivalent to negative eight
or another way to think about it,
if both of these sides are equal,
if I multiply the left side by something,
in order for the equality to hold true,
I have to multiply the right
side by the same thing.
And so this equation on the right,
this purple equation is
an equivalent equation
to our original one.
It looks different,
but the same x, y pairs
that satisfy this right equation
are going to satisfy this
left equation and vice versa.
Now another operation that
sometimes feels a little bit
less intuitive when you first learn it
when you're solving systems
is when you add two equations together.
So for example, we have
that purple equation,
the one that we've now
multiplied by negative one
and now we have our original,
I guess that's teal or blue equation.
So x plus y is equal to five.
And we learn when we're
solving systems of equations
that we can get a new equation
by adding the two left sides
and adding the two right sides.
And so you might have
seen something like this
when we add the two left sides,
let's see negative two x
plus x would be negative x
and then negative y plus y, well,
that's just going to cancel out
so we have no ys left
and then that's to be equal
to negative eight plus five
which is equal to negative three.
And before I even go on
to try to solve this,
why were we able to do that?
Pause this video and think about that.
Well, let me give you an example.
If we had started with
negative two x minus y
is equal to negative eight,
just as a single equation
and if I added five to both sides of that.
So if I added five
on the left hand side and I added five
on the right hand side,
I think that would've made
intuitive sense to you.
Negative two x minus y plus five
is equal to negative eight plus five.
Hopefully, this is a little bit intuitive
because once again, and I'm
really saying the same thing
over and over again,
the left side is truly
equal to negative eight.
So if I add five to it,
it's still going to be truly equal
to negative eight plus five.
So hopefully this makes a
little bit of intuitive sense.
And the key realization
with what we did up here is,
we essentially added five to both sides.
you see, you might say when
I know we only added five
to the right hand side but remember,
x plus y we are saying is equal to five
so it's just like adding the same thing
to both sides of the equation.
And then when you do that,
that's why we essentially
were able to eliminate this y variable
and now we got one
equation with one unknown
and then from there you can just do
a valid algebraic operation.
You could say, okay, I
just want to x over here.
What if I were to divide
both sides by negative one?
And once again, because negative x
is equal to negative three,
if I divide negative one
if I divide negative x by negative one,
I also have to divide
negative three by negative one
in order to maintain the equality.
And so then you're going to get,
x is equal to three.
And so that would be the
x value of that x, y pair
that satisfies both
and then to figure out the y value,
you would say, all right,
if x is equal to three,
I should be able to go back
into either of these equations
to find the corresponding y value
and it's a little bit easier
to go into that second one,
you could say, all right,
three plus is equal to five,
three plus y must be equal to five.
And then of course, if you
subtract three from both sides
'cause once again, we're saying,
three plus y is literally equal to five
then you're going to
get y is equal to two.
And so we found an x, y pair
that satisfies both equations
and really everything that
we wrote down over here,
these are all equivalent statements.
One of them is going
to be true if and only
the other statements, the
other equations are also true.
So two x plus y is equal to eight
and x plus y is equal to five
if and only if x equals
three and y equals two,
if and only if negative two x minus y
is equal to negative eight,
if and only if negative x
is equal to negative three.